"
♪
>> Greg: SO, DID SOMETHING
HAPPEN?
YEAH, AOUN PRECEDENTED LEAK AT
THE SUPREME COURT SENDING
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS INTO A
FRENZY.
BUT FOR DIFFERENT REASONS.
CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS
CONFIRMING THE AUTHENTICITY OF A
DRAFT OPINION THAT WOULD
OVERTURN ROE V. WADE WHILE
POINTING OUT THAT THE SUPREME
COURT HAS NOT MADE A FINAL
DECISION.
ROBERTS RIPPING THE LEAK AS AN
EGREGIOUS BREACH OF TRUST AND IS
ORDERING AN INVESTIGATION.
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND DEMOCRATS
IGNORING THE LEAK AND INSTEAD
ATTACKING REPUBLICANS AND
CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES ON THE
HIGH COURT.
>> IF THIS DECISION HOLDS, IT'S
REALLY QUITE A RADICAL DECISION.
>> THIS IS A DARK AND DISTURBING
MORNING FOR AMERICA.
>> THIS IS A FIVE ALARM FIRE.
>> WE NEED TO GET RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER AND ROE IS JUST
EXHIBIT A.
>> PART OF THIS NOVEMBER'S
ELECTION REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
WILL BE ON THE BALLOT.
>> THIS WOULD APPEAR TO BE AN
INVITATION TO HAVE, YOU KNOW,
HAND MAIDS TALE TYPE
ANTIFEMINIST REGULATION.
>> THESE JUSTICES ARE ACTING
LIKE THIS IS SOMEHOW SOMETHING
THAT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
CHANGE.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
CHANGE THIS.
>> Greg: THIS ISN'T COORDINATED
AT ALL.
DEMOCRATS ALSO TELLING THEIR
SUPPORTERS TO GET OUT THERE AND
PROTEST.
MEANWHILE REPUBLICANS SAY THE
LEAK WAS MEANT TO INTIMIDATE THE
JUSTICES INTO CHANGING THEIR
VOTE.
>> THE RADICAL LEFT IMMEDIATELY
RALLIED AROUND THE TOXIC STUNT
MAKING A LAST DITCH HAIL MARY
ATTEMPT TO CAUSE A POLITICAL
FIRESTORM AND CAUSE THE COURT TO
RECONSIDER.
>> DEMOCRATS REALLY DON'T SEE
THE RULE OF LAW OR THEIR COURT
INDEPENDENT PRINCIPLES ABOVE
POLITICS.
>> THAT'S A REAL SIGNIFICANT
BREACH OF TRUST.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
INSURRECTION.
THAT'S A JUDICIAL INSURRECTION.
>> Greg: IF ONLY WE HAD A JUDGE
HERE.
ALL RIGHT, JUDGE.
WHO DO YOU THINK LEAKED IT AND
WHY AND GIVE US YOUR ASSESSMENT
OF THIS WHOLE SCENE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON'T HAVE
THE SLIGHTEST IDEA WHO LEAKED IT
I WILL TELL YOU THIS, WHOEVER
LEAKED IT DID SOMETHING THAT IS
UNHEARD OF IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
YOU JUST DON'T LEAK A DECISION
BY ANY JUDGE, LET ALONE A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
I MEAN, THERE IS AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN BE PROUD OF
IS THAT THE JUSTICES ON THE
SUPREME COURT THEY CAN BE ON THE
OPPOSITE SIDE OF ISSUES.
BUT YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT THEM
NOT GETTING ALONG.
WE HEAR ABOUT SCALIA, RUTH BADER
GINSBURG THE BEST OF FRIENDS
ALTHOUGH IDEOLOGICALLY ON THE
OPPOSITE SIDE.
WHOEVER LEAKED THIS WE HAVE TO
FIND OUT WHO THE PERSON IS AND
CHARGE THEM WITH A CRIME.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CRIME
WOULD BE WHETHER IT'S SOME KIND
OF FRAUD ON GOVERNMENT PROPERTY.
I HEARD THERE IS A STATUTE FRAUD
ON A GOVERNMENT THAT COULD
IMPROVE THIS KIND OF ACT.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS IS IF
THEY WANT TO GIN UP THE LEFT WHO
WAS IN FOR ALLEGED BLOODBATH IN
NOVEMBER BY REPUBLICANS, THERE
IS NO BETTER WAY TO DO IT THAN
WITH ROE V. WADE.
IF YOU WILL JUST INDULGE ME FOR
A MINUTE.
I READ THE DECISION AT LENGTH
THE DOBBS DECISION AS WELL AS
ROE AGAIN.
ROE THEY SAY IS AN EXERCISE OF
RAW JUDICIAL POWER.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT IS A SUPREME
COURT ACTING AS LENGTHS
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
UNDERSTAND IF THIS DECISION IS
ULTIMATELY THE DECISION OF THE
COURT, IT DOESN'T OUTLAW
ABORTION.
ALL IT SAYS IS WE ARE SAYING
IT'S NOT A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
CONGRESS CAN PASS A LAW, SO
CHUCK SCHUMER SO FIRED UP, PASS
A LAW, CHUCK.
EVERY STATE CAN PASS ITS OWN
LAW.
THEY CAN -- NEGATE IT THEY CAN
BAN IT.
THEY CAN PROMOTE IT.
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO.
BUT THIS IS WHAT I THINK IS SO
STUNNING ABOUT IT.
THIS DECISION SAYS THERE IS NO
RIGHT TO ABORTION THAT IS
IMPLICIT IN THE CONSTITUTION.
NUMBER ONE IS IT THE
CONSTITUTION?
IS IT A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
FREEDOM OF SPEECH CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT.
FIRST AMENDMENT, RIGHT TO BEAR
ARMS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
SECOND AMENDMENT.
RIGHT TO ABORTION?
IT IS IMPLIED BASED UPON WHAT
ROE SAYS IS THE FOURTH, FIFTH,
NINTH, 14TH AMENDMENT AND I
WON'T GET INTO IT THEY SAID WE
DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE FOR SURE
BUT IT'S THROUGH THE DUE PROCESS
CLAUSE.
IN ORDER FOR IT TO BE PART OF
DUE PROCESS AND LEGAL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL, IT MUST BE A
TEACHLY ROOTED IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY AND TRADITION AND IT
MUST BE IMPLICIT IN ORDERED
LIBERTY.
IS ABORTION DEEPLY ROOTED IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY?
NO.
IN FACT, AT THE TIME OF ROE,
VIRTUALLY EVERY STATE OUTLAWED
ABORTION.
AND RIGHT BEFORE ROE, GOING BACK
TO THE COMMON LAW, IT WAS MURDER
AND THEN IT WAS REDUCED TO A
MISDEMEANOR AT SOME -- IN SOME
STATES.
AND IT IS -- IS IT IMPLICIT IN
THE CONCEPT OF ORDERED LIBERTY?
NO.
EVEN RUTH BADER GINSBURG SAID
THAT SO, THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
IS BASED, I THINK, VERY WELL ON
VERY WELL ARGUED AND, YOU KNOW,
IN ORDER FOR THE LEFT TO GET
EVERYONE FIRED UP, THEY WANT
SOMEONE ON THE RIGHT TO CAVE TO
THE MOB, THEY WANT TO INTIMIDATE
SOME JUSTICE ON THE RIGHT.
TO BACK UP AND SUPPORT IT.
BUT IT'S NOT A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT, LIKE SAME SEX MARRIAGE,
LIKE INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE, LIKE
CONTRACEPTIVE LOVING VS.
VIRGINIA.
GRISWOLD VS. CONNECTICUT ALL
THOSE CASES.
THIS INVOLVES A THIRD PARTY.
AND THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
THAT WAS PRETTY CLEAR.
I'M GOING TO JUST.
>> Dana: THANK YOU FOR COMING TO
HER TED TALK.
>> Greg: THE JUDGE BRINGS UP
HAVING VERY INTERESTING.
THE TIMING OF THIS AND WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS THAT THINGS ARE GOING
SO BAD FOR THE DEMOCRATS THAT
THEY NEED SOMETHING AND I MEAN,
THIS IS AN AMAZING DISTRACTION
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.
NOW, EVERYONE'S HAIR IS ON FIRE
INSTEAD OF TALKING ABOUT OR
FOCUSING ON INFLATION, CRIME,
THE BORDER.
>> Dana: I HAVE LOTS OF
DIFFERENT THOUGHTS.
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORTED ROE V. WADE
WERE LIVING ON BORROWED TIME AND
THEY KNEW IT BECAUSE THIS
DECISION AS A JUDGE HAS POINTED
OUT EVEN RUTH BADER GINSBURG
THIS THING WAS POORLY DECIDED AT
SOME POINT THAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THERE WAS A LOT OF CLAIMS TODAY
THIS IS THE DEATH OF DEMOCRACY
WHEN ACTUALLY WHAT HAPPENED IS
YOUR STATE LEGISLATURE WILL
DECIDE TO BRING IT UP AGAIN IN
SOME STATES LIKE COLORADO HAVE A
VERY, VERY PERMISSIBLE ABORTION
AND THEN YOU MIGHT HAVE ANOTHER
STATE LIKE MISSISSIPPI, THAT'S
GOING TO GO IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION.
BUT THE VOTERS WILL GET TO
DECIDE AND THAT IS WHAT ABOUT IN
OUR REPUBLIC.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
>> Greg: ROE V. WADE WAS
ANTI-DEMOCRATIC GAIN DEIGN
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Greg: THE SUPREME COURT IS
NOT A DEMOCRATIC CONSTITUTION.
>> Dana: SOMEBODY LIKE LIZ
WARREN WE MUST KILL THE
FILIBUSTER IN ORDER TO PASS IT.
THEY COULDN'T PASS IT EVEN IN
FEBRUARY.
THEY GOT 46 VOTES FOR A BILL
THEY WANTED TO CODIFY ROE.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
YOU HAVE AOC ATTACKING KYRSTEN
SINEMA TODAY SO THEY DON'T HAVE
THE VOTES.
THE INTERNAL DEMOCRATIC FIGHTING
WILL CONTINUE.
I ALSO THINK THAT YOU ARE GOING
TO HEAR A LOT ABOUT THAT THE
JUSTICES WHEN THEY WERE IN THEIR
CONFIRMATION PROCESS AND HAVE
PRIVATE MEETINGS WITH SENATORS.
TELL THEN WHAT YOU THOUGHT.
DO YOU THINK COVID SETTLED LAW.
THEY TOLD ME IT WAS SETTLED LAW.
WELL, YOU WILL HAVE SOME
SENATORS SAY THEY LIED TO ME.
AND SO THE QUESTION IS THEN WHY
AND I MAY -- WHEN THIS DECISION
ACTUALLY COMES OUT THERE WILL BE
A MORE WHOLESOME DISCUSSION TO
THAT AS TO WHY THIS HAPPENED OR
MAYBE THEY WILL DO AN INTERVIEW.
REMEMBER, SEPARATE BUT EQUAL WAS
SETTLED LAW UNTIL IT WASN'T AS
WELL.
THERE WAS A CASE BROUGHT BEFORE
THE COURT AND GONE THROUGH THE
SYSTEM.
EVEN THE LIBERALS KNEW THAT
MISSISSIPPI STATE LAW WHEN IT
GOT PASSED THEY THOUGHT OH BOY
HERE WE GOVERNMENT LAST POINT
WOULD BE THAT BOTH SIDES HAVE
GOTTEN EXACTLY WHAT THEY SAID IS
COMING FOR YEARS.
FOR HOWEVER LONG.
HOW LONG HAS PLANNED PARENTHOOD
BEEN TELLING EVERYBODY IF ROE IS
OVERTURNED WOMEN ARE GOING TO
DIE AND BE SECOND CLASS
CITIZENS.
WHICH IS WHY YOU HAVE PEOPLE
THINK THAT.
IF YOU ELECT REPUBLICANS
PRESIDENTS AND REPUBLICAN
SENATORS AND YOU NOMINATE
CONSERVATIVE JUDGES, THEN YOU
WILL GET TO OVERTURN ROE V.
WADE.
SO NOW BOTH SIDES ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE FALLOUT ON
IT.
>> Greg: YEAH, YOU KNOW, JOEY,
WHAT SCARES ME ABOUT THIS
DECISION IT'S OBVIOUSLY GOING TO
TARGET THE TRULY MARGINALIZED
AND I SPEAK OF PREGNANT MEN.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Joey: I HAVE A LOT OF
THOUGHTS.
THE LEAK STANDS IN ITSELF IS
CONTROVERSY.
OTHER IS WHAT HAPPENED HOW
ABORTION IS HANDLED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
ONE THING I WANT TO REMIND
PEOPLE IS THAT PEOPLE SITTING AT
HOME WATCHING RIGHT NOW AREN'T
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLARS.
AND WE ACCEPT THAT THERE IS A
RELIGIOUS RIGHT AND THERE IS A
VERY LIBERAL PROGRESSIVE LEFT
THAT ARE VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE.
THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
MIDDLE THAT HAVE AN OPINION ON
THIS ISSUE.
EVERY AGNOSTIC PERSON EVER HELD
A CHILD HAS AN OPINION.
EVERY SINGLE MOTHER EVER BEEN IN
A PLACE WHERE SHE FELT LIKE
BETWEEN A ROCK AND HARD PLACE
AND THE WORSE CIRCUMSTANCE HAS
AN OPINION ON THIS ISSUE.
THAT'S WHY THE SUPREME COURT
LOOKS AT THIS ISSUE AS
UNSETTLEDsED AS LAW IN THE
LAND THAT'S WHY IT'S PROBABLY
IMPORTANT SOMEONE WHO IS EVEN
PRO-ABORTION BLUE A
CONSTITUTIONALIST ROE V. WADE
PROBABLY OVERREACHED AND DIDN'T
ALLOW THE PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
TO MAKE THIS DECISION BECAUSE IT
MAY BE THE MOST COMPLEX ISSUE WE
DECIDE AS A ITS THAT.
WE ARE ASKING THE QUESTION WHAT
IS LIFE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
CONCEPTION AND CONSCIOUSNESS.
THAT'S A HARD ISSUE TO EXPLAIN
OR TO DEFINE AND SCIENCE ISN'T
THERE THAT'S WHY THE SUPREME
COURT STRUGGLED WITH THIS.
THAT'S WHY SO MANY PEOPLE
STRUGGLED WITH ROE V. WADE.
>> Greg: JESSICA, LAST WORKED TO
YOU.
>> Jessica: A LOT OF WORDS.
I WAS SHOCKED BY THIS.
I REALLY DID NOT EXPECT 9:00
THAT SUDDENLY THIS WOULD BE WHAT
WAS HAPPENING.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S SOMETHING THAT
LIBERALS HAVE WARNED OF AND THAT
CONSERVATIVES HAVE LONG WANTED
SO I GUESS IT'S NOT A COMPLETE
SURPRISE.
THE TIMING IS STRANGE.
I HAVE SEEN FEASIBLE ARGUMENTS
FOR WHY IT WAS A LIBERAL CLERK
THAT LEAKED THIS AND WHY IT WAS
A CONSERVATIVE CLERK WHO LEAKED
THIS.
BECAUSE IF IT WAS A
CONSERVATIVE, IT MIGHT BE
SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO KEEP ALL
THE FIVE JUDGES ON THE SIDE OF
ALITO'S OPINION IN THEIR BOX
THERE AND THEY DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE ANY ROOM FOR PUSHBACK
PROBABLY ON SOMEONE LIKE JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH WHO I THINK IN THAT
GROUP WOULD BE THE MOST LIKELY
TO SVEDA ROBERTS WHO IT SEEMS
LIKE IS NOT WITH THE GROUP OF
FIVE AND WRITING A SEPARATE
CONCURRENCE.
LEAKING IS BAD.
THERE HAVE BEEN PARTS BEFORE
ORIGINAL ROE DECISION WAS
PARTIALLY LEAKED.
60% BELIEVE ABORTION SHOULD BE
LEGAL IN ALL OR MOST CASES.
MOST CASES IS WHERE WE GET INTO
TROUBLE IN JOEY'S POINT.
PEOPLE WANT TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT A VIABILITY
DATE.
RIGHT?
THAT I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE AT
LEAST AT THIS TABLE THAT THESE
LAWS THAT HAVE COME INTO PLACE
IN CONSERVATIVE STATES LIKE
MISSISSIPPI TALKING ABOUT SIX
WEEK ABORTION BANS.
I WAS RECENTLY PREGNANT.
DID I NOT KNOW I WAS PREGNANT AT
THE SIX WEEK MARK.
I WANTED MY BABY.
I AM THRILLED TO HAVE MY
DAUGHTER THAT DOESN'T MEAN I
SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
MY OWN HEALTHCARE DECISIONS
STRIPPED AWAY FROM ME BECAUSE I
HAPPEN TO LIVE IN THAT STATE.
WHAT ELIZABETH WARREN WAS
TALKING ABOUT AND EVERYONE CAN
MAKE FUN OF HER ABOUT HER
HYSTERICAL NATURE.
SHE IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
THIS LAW WILL HURT POOR WOMEN.
THIS LAW WILL HURT WOMEN WHO DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO GOOD
HEALTHCARE.
I'M AN UPPER MIDDLE CLASS WHITE
WOMAN I WILL BE ABLE TO GET
WHATEVER HEALTHCARE I WANT FOR
THE REST OF MY LIFE.
THAT IS NOT TRUE OF WOMEN WHO
ARE STRUGGLE GLICK.
PEOPLE WORKING TWO JOBS AND ALSO
THE MAJORITY OF WOMEN WHO GET
ABORTIONS GUESS WHAT?
THEY HAVE ALREADY BEEN MOTHERS.
THEY ARE PEOPLE MAKING FAMILY
PLANNING DECISIONS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT TEENAGERS
RUNNING AROUND AND GETTING
PREGNANT IN A CAR OR SAYING I
DON'T CARE.
OR PEOPLE WHO THINK ABORTION IS
THE SAME AS THE MORNING AFTER
PILL.
IT IS NOT.
IT IS THE MOST CAREFULLY
CONSIDERED DECISIONS THAT A
WOMAN MAKES.
AND THAT'S WHY THIS LAW WAS SO
IMPORTANT.
IT WAS ABOUT PRIVACY.
THAT I SHOULD BE ABLE TO GO INTO
A ROOM WITH MY DOCTOR AND MAKE A
DECISION.
>> A LOT TRY TO INFLUENCE THEM
TO GET AN ABORTION.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
IT IS A NUANCES THING THAT EVERY
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL HAS TO MAKE
FOR THEMSELVES AND THAT MIGHT BE
WHY STATES SHOULD DECIDE AS A
CULTURE AND A SOVEREIGN STATE
HOW THEY ARE GOING TO HANDLE IT.
>> WHY SHOULD YOU BE SOMEONE WHO
CAN'T LIVE IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS, FOR INSTANCE, BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO CONTROL
YOUR OWN BODY?
AND I'M SO SICK ALSO SEEING ON
TELEVISION PEOPLE SCREAMING I
WAS INFRINGINGEN THEIR RIGHTS
BECAUSE I ASKED THEM TO WEAR A
MASK.
TELLING ME THAT I HAVE TO HAVE A
BABY THAT I DON'T NECESSARILY
WANT OR.
>> REVERSE THAT ARGUMENT WITH
THE VACCINES AS WELL.
>> Jessica: I WOULD STILL ARGUE
IS A SHOT IN YOUR ARM IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN A
COMMITMENT TO A PERSON FOR 18
YEARS.
REPUBLICANS ALSO, NO SUPPORT FOR
THE SOCIAL SERVICES THAT THEY
WANT TO DO.
THEY JUST SAY HAVE A BABY AND
DEAL WITH IT.
>> Greg: I THINK THE ASSUMPTION
THAT THE POOR HELPING THE POOR
BY GIVING THEM MORE ABORTIONS
SEEMS GROSS TO ME.
>> Jessica: GIVING THEM OPTIONS.
>> Greg: OF COURSE, THAT'S WHAT
WE CALL IT MEDIA INFLAMI